friend and she notes that speech employs
both acoustic and gestural forms of
signals while print text is a sequence
of visual signals right so this page is
full of things I'm looking at they're
not gesturing and they're not acoustic
yet so this clarification is reminding
us that any translation of one system
say acoustic and gestural to print is
what she calls an interest mi otic
translation we have to acknowledge that
that's happening that the semiotic of
one system is moving into the semiotic
said another was a translation second
that verbal speech has several signaling
channels and that print texts we see
primarily through vision so we can look
at a couple of things like para
linguistics and George Trager who wrote
a book named than many books but this
particular article paralanguage of first
approximation talks about vocal delivery
and there are aspects called vocal set
vocalizations and vocal qualities and
you can imagine there are many many
aspects there you don't need to go into
them but to acknowledge that there are
there's actually a taxonomy there and
that we could look at those three
categories and the multiple options
within them and how they all interact
and how they actually communicate yes
and second of all that labored whistle
has developed a parallel system of
analysis called para kinesics that is to
say all the bodily gestures that go
along with all of those parallel
existence and there are many many again
so if you can imagine all of those
variables in peril linguists and all
those variables and perica musics and
how they all multiply interact with each
other that's a very complex system and
it's worth paying attention to the fact
that they're there and earlier I
mentioned that we are these wonderful
Studies on trauma in oral history and
the idea that that trauma is an
experience in the body and that the body
can sometimes block the illusionary but
what I will say repeating from earlier
that the body is always present so if
you talk about silence you're actually
did
in fact the body's speaking that verbal
silence that there is in fact even in a
in a el badi by la bonne lumen analysis
perspective that is in fact about eating
using downflow that battle flow is
active in the body of being pail and so
maybe there's a way which you can free
that flow through mirroring and so on
but the body is present and the body is
actually communicating so there is
actually for me really no silence and
interviews if you take into account of
all that embody channels of
communication so um next I just briefly
want to talk a little bit about
contingency first of all we all know the
oral history interviews are embedded in
a social communication system so we are
interested actively involved with our
with our narrators that the responses of
the narrator is always emergent and
regards to the questions and that's why
we record the questions and that's why
we keep the questions because that is a
dialogue as emerging there and so just
to touch on that idea of contingency
that and i use bakhtin as an example but
i know that there's some in the people
who work in those areas of opportunity
and theory that the wash it off and
bactine it's not sure which person said
it because it in the kind of soviet-era
early Soviet I where things got me it's
done but i'll just say bakhtin for now
but this idea of utter in theory that in
fact you cannot speak unless you're
actually responding to another utterance
that is always at donna logic formation
of knowledge coming from a body to a
bombing right so remember that that
dialogue is not just speech it is also
the body so that dialogic formation is
contingent it's contingent on the social
situational variables of that
munication system so so those areas of
contingency are very important and I
just want to expand that idea briefly
because I know you guys reach port le
and Trust Dooley of course it's a text
that suggests that there are many other
variables in the social situation beyond
the actual present bodies of the
interview that there are the family
norms and values the neighborhood social
situations and special even church in
that particular case and statewide
ideologies at all are part of those
contingent variables they're just not
actually physically present so all of
those variables are contingent in this
situation and that's quite a lot going
on there so I just want to say that oral
histories contingent oral histories and
body and then I'm glad just talk about
how oral history is also temporal so
today I'm going to talk about some
philosophy and it's it's you know I'm
late to philosophy but it nags at me and
I feel Holden to that discipline to
answer some questions that are that are
really important for me so despite the
bad rap that Martin Heidegger gets to
some degree participatory and not CD
ologies I'm going to use some of that
occur and I'm also going to speak up to
paul ricoeur and another phenomenologist
jaan photo shoot up a check I'm going to
talk about their approaches to embody
practices and temporality and how that
informs the production of documentary
performance so as you know I'm
interested in not only recording the
oral histories of performing artists but
also then using performance as a form of
research inquiry to know more about the
interview so documentary performance as
you may know is works that are based on
kinds of documents and I'll get into
that but let me just introduce here the
idea that embodiment and temporality are
very important aspects of documentary
performance and especially in the case
of choreography based oral history
interviews so I'm really trying to link
dance and oral history in this in this
presentation and my talk today is framed
by the University of Tel Aviv professor
Frannie wrote poems conceptualization of
the actor as a hyper historian in his
text performing history berroco the
hyper historian becomes vote the
connecting link between historical past
and the fictional performed here are now
a quote to accomplish this task the
actor must strengthen or reinforce the
dialectics among multiple time registers
in order to provide a critical
perspective on both present and past
events and the telling of events on
stage I suggest the professor welcomes
articulation of the actors a hyper
historian can be expanded to the
choreographers role as a dramaturgical
agent in revealing and making explicit
philosophical comments on performance
and temporality so two documentary
theatre it's a genre of performance that
relies on a variety of sources such as
photographs drawings paintings prints
and other and other notational systems
life documents which is correspondence
video oral interviews blogs and various
ephemera and practitioners of
documentary theatre have a long history
but you know probably anna deavere smith
and moises kaufman and it's jack tonic
theatre
they're local folks here in the city to
name just two among many who performed
theatrical productions worldwide and are
published in a variety of disciplines
including theatre performance studies
and if you're interested Johnny
saldanha's recent book etho drama offers
it to a typology of types and criteria
for analysis if you're interested in
further look shaumbra most scholarly
studies a large proportion of
documentary theatre works are focused on
text-based performance other sub genres
such as music and dance works and in
particular we're all history interviews
and choreography intersex are relatively
unexplored subgenres of documentary
theatre theory and practice nonverbal
are embodied communication channels of
oral history interviews can contribute
vocabulary for theatrical
representations of documents including
full body movements posture shifts limb
hand facial gestures as well as the
physical aspects of vocal production and
nonverbal vocals like laughing and
coughing and crying these embodied
sources are transformed through
choreographic inquiry into performance
events the few works of this
choreographic show sub-genre documentary
theatre include choreographer mark
taylor's large-scale work titled witness
commemorating the Kent State murders of
1970 25 years later and my own works in
time the muscle memory and the
Sorcerer's Apprentice as though you are
CER
darkness emerging from oral history
sources documenting San Francisco Bay
Area dance communities in the latter
works the sources are mined from legacy
and oral history program I founded in
nineteen eighty-eight now archived at
the San Francisco Museum of performance
and design today I'm exploring how
choreographic works based on oral
historical materials are a form of
inquiry that explicate philosophical
approaches to embodiment and temporality
as a new type of hyper historian first
I'm proposing that the oral history
method is a practice of what philosopher
Martin Heidegger calls care whores or go
that which expresses a person's interest
in their own existence as a being in the
world Heidegger argues that care is the
source of existential authenticity for
human beings when we become capable of
full awareness of our existence this
awareness means that we become
intelligible to ourselves within the
structures of the world that is given to
us without this awareness Heidegger
suggests that we reduce our lives to an
average pneus that limits our capacity
for full experience of living oral
history interviewing can be instrumental
in the project of existential
authenticity further I propose that
embodied practices such as dance enable
us to fully complete this awareness
process my presentation is meant to
explore how existential philosophy or
history and dance together combined to
fulfill our capacity for awareness
through documentary performance first
let's take a look at oral history as a
particular form of historical
documentary production the oral history
interview as an advantage is a special
environment that provides possibilities
for heidegger's care approaching care
for our existential being is
accomplished through oral history
because the interview is a framing
mechanism that explicitly brackets the
individual as a being within one's own
life trajectory that bracketing if that
happens because during the interview a
person's life in trajectory is placed
into relief as a timely set of events
and I use timely both in the sense of
meaning meaningfulness that is Purdue
through self-reflection but also timely
in terms of these events temporality the
oral history interview is an exercise
and temporality than is the combination
of various time tenses a past present
and future into a single combined
experience of time this combined
experience is accomplished by using an
interview to reflect on one's past as it
is remembered in the present parsing
this temporality further each of these
past events is remembered as if they are
present again but thinking about the
future effects of one's actions these
events become what Trek philosopher
Yamamoto should go call the Kwazii pass
the Kwazii present and the quasi future
so I'm quoting photography here humans
are constantly placing themselves into
situations other than the directly
present ones into the past into the
future with all their Kwazii structures
remembering is going into the horizon of
the past where a course of life that had
once since hudson's is repeated as
tokens we moved in the past as if it
were present hence Kwazii present
remember also that each Kwazii present
that is remember it eventually becomes a
quazy past moment in the life review and
each Kwazii present is associated with
its quazy future which will then become
the next Kwazii present as one continues
in the self-reflection process to new
points along the historical continuum so
it's basically a replacement so the past
becomes the present future then becomes
the president's you move forward the
course that means you can back and forth
in either direction in this way the oral
history interview embeds the narrator in
a continual temporarily defined way of
being and this quality of embedding
oneself fully into temporality brings me
back to heidegger as existential care
emerges from temporality my next step is
to then link this idea of the interview
as a project of immersion into
temporalities linking that immersion
with action
specifically actions of the body
Heidegger argues that one's
understanding of being in the world
emerges from encountering objects in the
world and then engaging them in a
practical manner as a way of making
world these encounters sorry dinner
these encounters the world of practice
are defined by 10 gin in action the act
of doing with things and with people as
we encounter them how do your argues
that this is doing this world of
practice is defined by temporality let
me explain explain further the
connection between temporality and
practice any action of doing in the
present is driven by one's reflection on
the past experience this reflection on
the past evolves into a wish a desire a
need to do something now in the present
based on your desire from the past so
any current moment of practice in the
president merges from and is informed by
one's past simultaneously our need to
act in the present is driven by
trajectory into the future how that
wishes to be fulfilled a desire for the
projected future result of one's actions
in the present for Heidegger when one is
deeply immersed in a practice the past
president future all merge into an
experience of full temporality meet hot
chicks and meet high a check
psychologist is written about this
embodied experience calling it flow when
we become so immersed in the action of
doing time seems to disappear however
for Heidegger time doesn't disappear as
much as fuse into what he calls the
ecstasies a fully integrated temporality
how does this process bring us into full
authenticity we cannot have a world in
the abstract we must engage the world
through practice of doing in order for
the world including its objects and
other beings to disclose themselves to
us a fully disclosed world is one in
which the human being becomes fully
aware of his or her being in that world
of what harder calls being in the world
all one word historians are interested
in creating a record of past actions
these past actions include one's
motivations for doing that action and
proposed future outcomes of those
actions therefore patoshik is quazy time
structure and high degrees temporality
of being are useful models for the oral
historian because the interview event
itself frames the process of reflecting
on these actions informed by all three
aspects of quazy time oral history gives
access to what hire calls care that
situation in which a beam becomes
explicitly interested in their own being
put another way the oral history event
places us in a situation that allows us
to explicitly care about our own game as
it is defined by immersion in
temporality through reflection on
encounters with objects and beings in
the world now something short about
hermeneutics how the subject of an oral
history interview composes their
narrative about that framed experience
of care becomes a separate product the
narrative itself thus narrative is also
a uniquely temporal realized outcome as
philosopher paul ricoeur notes in his
text time and narrative narratives
emerge as a collection of temporal I
statements about actions in the world
recur goes further to say that the
narrative structure that is how we tell
the story of our experiences is a
metaphor for heidegger's timely care
collecting historical actions into a
story structure directly references
heidegger's temporal way of being even
to the point of constructing a narrative
that projects us into the possibility of
authenticity to describe this projection
require uses the rhetorical trope of
metaphor where a descriptive image is
construed in constant relationship to
its reference in the case of oral
history the narrative is the metaphor
the descriptive image where its
reference is one's temporal care for
being there for storytelling itself is a
portal to authenticity to recurse
metaphorical
permission consequently there is an
ongoing shimmering effect between two
objects there is the constructed
narrative and there is the metaphorical
reference of temporal care in an oral
history this metaphorical effect occurs
because the subject immerses itself in
all three aspects of kwasi time while
the same time reflecting on the past
when the perspective of the current
present the switching of temporal codes
between the present and Kwazii time
brings the subject into a new type of
consciousness at hermeneutic
consciousness this hermeneutic
consciousness is all about
interpretation a repeated circle of
sending out to the past and then
returning back to the present so that
one can interpret self experience toward
understanding so I've just finished my
remarks with a specific image a metaphor
that consciously evokes the shimmering
movement between metaphor and its
reference I suggest that to complete the
hermeneutic circle I have drawn in order
for the oral history subject to come
fully aware of their care movement must
be considered and considering movement
there is necessarily a body that moves
for Heidegger that being that cares
about beings called design for Heidegger
design is not I've never had about it
does I'm caixas purely at the
ontological level since Heidegger
published his work being in time many
philosophers have asked this question
where is the existent body in his work
is this philosophical treatise on
existential being completely disembodied
after all as I mentioned earlier the
centerpiece of his philosophical
argument is practice that is how one
encounters the objects of the world who
do it is not doing an embodied
experience is not embodied experience at
the core of care and therefore at the
core of our fulfillment of existential
awareness Christians jockin in his
article for research and phenomenology
asks what is the significance about the
absence of the living body and how
teachers analytic
design so I'm not the only one asking
this question the author notes this
absence has taken the interest of
several authors and I list them all here
and in particular citing sale can
unaccounted this practice we are led
into an operetta into an ontological
solipsistic unquote in his article
Heidegger in the absence of the body
philosopher Brian Bowles asked the same
question Bulls quite both several
philosopher whose waited on the same
concern Sartre well familiar and much we
could complaint one cannot find six
lines on the problem of the body and
being a time well and so um when I was
in France fert on a Fulbright I decided
to bring not only being in time and not
only freak the three-volume version of
workers narrative texts but also a new
text call is Allah Connor seminar and
this to me is a really interesting text
because it was a group of psychiatrists
in Switzerland who were all asking
Heidegger this question where is the
body because they found that his
existential structure was actually
potentially useful for a psychiatric
form of somatic treatment for people
with existential crises and of course
Santiago psychiatrists are interested in
body they're engaged in the soma so
they're asking in this question hunter
actually went down to the Swiss area
where they were located once a year for
ten years to actually just sit in a room
and be peppered with their questions
about what is the body and met our boss
who is the guy who compiled all of these
into a text called the sala con or
seminar addresses these same questions
from the perspective of a psychiatric
profession is there a possibility for
the medical profession to develop as
existentialist approach to psychiatric
treatment and if so what is the role of
a body and heidegger's cumulative have
your response quote the living body is
the most difficult to think as see on
cam notes for Heidegger the body only
appears in passing never tackled in
itself before itself reduced to a
surprising significance did he neglect
the human being capable of moving itself
and setting itself into motion well when
I get that you know as a dancer I'm
really excited to see someone talking
about movement in regards to heidegger
into how the body is implicated they're
countering these complaints those sites
muckle David Levin's text the body's
recollection on being in which the
author discovers insights notable
references to the body and hard eaters
text however 11 admits that heidegger's
references are limited to a slightly
different for an important caveat on the
idea of embodiment Heidegger wants us to
pay attention to the capacities of
bodies rather than the fleshly
experience of these bodies I know that
feels like parsing things rather Finley
but it's important in the German
language bodies are considered both live
and corporate I don't know who speaks
German here but as I understand as it
has been explained to me who does not
speak German that corporate is the
actual meat the flesh but live is
actually an expandable responsive
reactionary being to its environment
it's a much more mobilized kind of
concept about the body so that to me is
speaking to what hive your is addressing
the kind of capacities of body person
flush itself check philosopher yawn
piuttosto who I addressed before says
that this dynamic body which moves and
sets itself into motion says that it is
unlimited that is to say we as bodies
skip over the experience of our bodies
coping with
world those capacities that live that we
are and focus instead on the objects of
people's we encounter as high degree
notes when he generates the neologism
laibin that is we are existing in the
mode of body or more commonly referred
to as quote body and forth but only
existing but not thinking is specific as
I suggest that the FEMA ties ation
petrushka finds absent and is looking
for her specifically in dance dancers
aren't thinking explicitly as a body
through rigorous training that develops
a functional understanding of embodied
practice that eventually blends into the
experience of embodied thinking dancers
train our bodies in order to know it
explicitly through a series of self
analytic phenomenological experiences
for example pitaj book calls for a
better understanding of diamond dynamism
of body movement dance studies provides
a system of observation analysis
notation of the over 100 possible
combinations of dynamism within the lava
movement analysis system the system of
explicit dynamism organizes informs
motivates movement in the classroom and
in performance so there is a system out
there for actually explicitly FINA
tising dynamism in the toshka also
suggests we only generally orient
ourselves through the body in order to
cope with the environment on the
contrary dancers specifically orient the
body within space among multiple axes
horizontal vertical and sagittal and
because dance movement is ultimately
three-dimensional all three taxis are
integrated to create a practice of what
I would call hyper orientation this
hyper orientation in space is especially
crucial in performance where one's own
body is hyper oriented in relation not
only to the theaters spatial context but
also simultaneously to other bodies
similarly oriented and orienting that is
to say change it in multiple dynamic
relationships to one's own body so let
me give you one experience when I'm
performing and I step onto a proscenium
stage you can imagine there's a curtain
on the side
I'm standing here and I'm trying to warm
up something like this and one of the
things that you have to think about when
you're orienting yourself in a
proscenium stage it's not to the corners
of the stage itself because if you're
watching to the corner you're really
kind of ignoring the audience's you
actually have to orient yourself to this
larger space called the theater so the
corners of this rib are my axes than the
corner here so I have to think of myself
as projecting my body-- virtually into
that whole space not the limited space
of the proscenium itself secondly I'll
just give you one experience when i was
performing a work about Virginia Woolf
and her milieu we were using we were
multiple characters in that project and
there were four guys from I think it was
Cambridge it's an Oxford Cambridge I
can't remember but um II they're all
lovers and they all sort of chain gang
with each other and it kind of certain
young person kind of way and so there
was several men doing duets across the
space and they kept moving and
dynamically changing relation to each
other well at one point I was just
supposed to stand at the back of the
stage and throw myself up and over and
trust that I'm going to be caught in the
back and that trustworthy person was my
friend Frank and he was always like
running around here and like when he was
writing I just knew that I was ready and
I gonna trust me there I'm orienting
myself to my back space right so there's
a hyper orientation that you have to be
aware in relationship to the moving body
that you're going to have should be
caught by hopefully in a few seconds so
in these ways I suggest that dance
explicitly frames heidegger's coping
with objects and bodies in the world
dance clears a space of hyper oriented
and orienting disclosure of the world to
explicit doing this brings us into a
fuller authenticity of being but also
suggests that beyond dancing itself as
an experienced the active choreography
is akin to the active wickers narrative
in this way I returned to our attention
to recur a narrative is a metaphorical
reference to temper reality I suggest
the choreography is another form of
narrative construction not focused on
words
focused on the phenomena of movement
oriented in space and time to quote
Patricia's concerns choreography is the
carefully organized framing and
presentation of explicitly Thema tised
movement dynamics furthermore within its
relatively short duration choreography
can be perceived as both the dancers and
the audience as a highly compressed
version of all three aspects that
patoshik is quazy time because
choreography is a temporal art the
performance is explicitly framed by
duration time without the benefit of any
explicit traits in the form of a
sculptural object or two-dimensional
painting or drawing dances by definition
temporal and choreography is the art of
making that temporal duration meaningful
for example the first action presented
in a choreography will always frame the
rest of the temporal display that
follows the audience must retain that
frame as it is first presented in order
to make dramaturgical order of the rest
of the choreography by doing so the
audience is following the choreographers
cube to experience this first framing
event as the quasi past at the
choreography continues in the quazy
present and as we have seen in my
earlier discussions of rural history
each of these quazy presents turns into
a quazy past that they accumulate if the
duration / ography goes on the process
of an audience acquiring the
choreographic narrative accumulation
multiple closet timeframes turned into
high degrees ecstasy's of temporality
this dramaturgical acquisition provides
audiences and performances the same
access for care for existential being as
yorkers narrative metaphor choreography
is a framed experience of full
temporality inscribed by thinking bodies
explicitly dynamite and hyper oriented
space so this paper is a proposition for
more exploration the work of Heidegger
Patricia can recur provide us with a
framework to support a focus on
embodiment of
multi in oral history based choreography
both oral history and choreography of
the potential to bring us into full
temporal consciousness and therefore
disclosure of world the combination of
the oral history method and dance
provide us with an opportunity for
further exploration of full disclosure
of human existential awareness through
the choreographer as Wilkins hyper
historian in the documentary theatre
production where choreography is the
primary medium through which content is
framed there are opportunities to use
all the methods described above to
theatrically clear a space so let me
just briefly mention that this plus is
turning into the chapter that any
suggestion of a memory extreme there
then we get your performance being
published by palgrave in the university
of ottawa theatre department and
tomorrow i'm flying to Buenos Aires for
nine days actually worked with a
choreographer from Frankfurt when I was
in front for an Argentinian Grutter for
requested my mentorship run world
history creating choreography she made
an amazing work she made a work with a
German choreographer let's inside who
would immigration to argentina before
World War two and she actually worked
with secondary interviews about a dozen
secondary and what she found out is that
the mythology of this choreographer
whose name is renata short Elias was
that she did one thing but in fact with
the interview she discovered with this
person to completely other things so
there was an interesting problem there
and what was wonderful about the work
that she created is it as a choreography
about that gap between the mythology and
in fact what was generated through the
archival process of all his two
positions so what when is most
interesting for me in the project again
using brokens framework were the various
theatrical modes in which she
enabling us to perceive gas so for
example the first thing you see in the
performance is actually a print period
print dress of that like 50s and 60s and
it's hanging at person height but it's
completely flattened on a cardboard and
the soul of us the only performer in the
piece that dances comes up can you still
see me if I go Karen so here's here's
the dress and she comes up and she is
like trying to become three-dimensional
with this dress so the perception is
that there's a tomb in two dimension now
they cannot achieve three dimensionality
and the gap between the living body and
the flat body are not possible that's
not commenced formal and so that's the
first thing you actually experience is
the gap between those the other about
other the one that I think is most
interesting is where she has video taped
an interview and she places it on a
video monitor downstage and then the
soloist is actually behind that video
monitor trying to perform every movement
that that that narrator is doing and
obviously it's impossible for her to
sink that up it's always behind or ahead
or not quite exactly the same movement
so that gap is clearly there and what
she's done the choreographer his John is
she's actually edited that interview so
that every time there's a rough edit the
the soloist actually scrapes her chair
back and has to start over so she gets
further further behind both temporally
and spatially so by the time it reached
its really to like this and it's like
you're tearing this suturing that you
think happens between this performance
and this video monitor is being like
it's like ripping off tape room every
time by the time she's finished she's in
the back of the performance desperately
trying to fulfill this gap that has not
actually been
so there are several theatrical
choreographic ways in which she's
actually pointed to this guy and in that
way I think she's really fulfilling this
hyper historian as choreographer aspect
and I'm looking at so I'm actually
giving another paper down when Osiris
next thursday i'm actually before that
force performance so just to say this
get more going this idea yeah can you
talk about in your own work
choreographing the ant species based on
their drawing from oral histories and
how you just how do you jump with the
body several experience in the world
history and the embodied several
experience of the dance performance and
then the gaps and differences the chain
done yeah well there's a particular
section of my work called muscle memory
where Frank who I mentioned about to
leap into his own Frank head hiv/aids
and when I interviewed him that was part
of the process and Frank as I mentioned
earlier the pre was had an opportunist a
virus that caused him to develop
dementia and I said it Frank would you
like to stop he said no I want you to
actually document this process of me
losing my life so I did and actually for
me that was one of the most core
powerful aspects of the interview is so
I did actually construct a part of the
work which deliberately mixes different
periods of the interview so I'm
specifically meaning to be confusing but
so for example Frank when he was HIV
AIDS and decided to retire at the age of
26 from this dance company he was a
creep the car for created a solo for him
solo name Sweet William in which he
reveled in himself and at the same time
talks about in the oral history that
while he was performing that last
performance all I could think of was his
whole life trajectory at the same so
there was that experience of describing
that performance and that reflectiveness
on it so like time passed Kwazii past
also Frank his mother who was a biker
babe from New Jersey came to Byzantine
era and Joyce didn't actually know where
the hospital was where he had all this
treatment and one that one morning Frank
woke up paralyzed from the waist down
and he said I'm in a panic I don't know
what to do and so I said where do we go
I said go to the hospital but he
wouldn't remember either where the
hospital bus said there was driving up
and down the hills of san Cisco looking
they were weeping it was terrible and
then also Frank up in his heyday was
also about a company where he performed
a solo by Anna Sokolow called panic so
there were these interesting ways in
which these aspects of the narrative
were intertwined with this idea of panic
and so I actually selected elements and
then I mixed them so that they kept
shifting into one another so they kept
shifting between different temporalities
within the narrative and then pouria
graph that so that was given in a way
that was i'll call it Kwazii coherent
and it was meant actually to be not
quite coherent I think back with the
point of the performance was to give
that
so that would be one example I have to
admit that to work performance in oral
history it's kind of kind of scary it's
one that I'm not your boy because I
think the performance has not authentic
so it definitely fluence is the way that
I interact with my narrow my decision
not to use video because I don't want
them near before and then in my mind it
would take away from the truth so but
when I started becoming more familiar
with your work it's my reading the
essays that you suggested I immediately
started thinking well how in this realm
of theatre in the storm of performance
can we come back the issue of not always
getting the authentics or maybe getting
the fantastical and they exaggerate and
and so I was writing in in your essay
just now you were mentioning a hyper
historian in that connection between
history and fiction so do you even feel
the need to try to challenge the
performance and the aspect of
exaggeration that comes with that well
first I want to recognize that that
concern because that's an important
concern that people start performing for
the camera and not really giving an
interview I think that in some ways I'm
lucky in that the cohort I was focused
on our group of people who are
professional performers and so I have to
say that for me at least many of my
colleagues and perform not on the stage
the last thing they want to do is go so
it's almost like a retreat from that
world and the other thing I'll say is
that I don't know if you've had this
experience but you know when you're when
you're on stage getting ready in the
curtains closed and look the booms are
coming down the curtains are moving
you're trying to like just do your plie
and just focus you get really really
good at just doing what you're doing and
not worrying about all the stuff around
you that and so if there's lights and
there's a
camera actually about that particular
culprit is really actually good at being
themselves in that place because their
practice at school but I would also say
that there's nothing wrong with the
fantastical you know what is oral
history it is a subjective slice its
partial by definition and it is interest
objective movies that work right and so
let's admit that let's live inside that
let's allow that to be so if that's what
you're getting that's what you're
getting and so you know it is necessary
for us to look at the interpretation
process in sort of note what the
conditions were under which it was
performed you know talk about the
biography now that might have been
interacted with it but that's real too
that's your chill there's no truth so
far as I'm concerned yeah um you're your
work is very much stimulating to me
because I'm I'm a big music fans on and
in fact that you're using dance to tell
these stories I'm curious as to your
methodology when selecting music are
there all original scorers on the they
are they popular musing and if so how
exactly are you coordinating they so
it's in I guess in sync with the dance
and then the hood of the body so that
isn't Ellen is comprehensible injury
well I'll speak from two perspectives
one for my own work in muscle memory
there is no music per se but there are
recordings and recordings are and actors
a rendition of some edited versions of
the oral history but they are also
coached they are dramatized so that
there's one section which I ask the
person so another interview was with an
elder in her late 80s who had a
wonderful amazing life who danced in New
York with a
honey hole so this woman was born of
Polish parents in San Bernardino
California and had to run away from home
to be a dancer and she finally got to
New York by driving an elderly educator
across the United States in her 40 for
Packer at 40 miles an f1 and she wanted
to stop at all these college campuses to
just soak it in and very frustrating for
this again Kristen he wanted to start
her career so she was like come on come
on so when she got there she was
immediately met by her brother and she
said goodbye and never going to honey
home studio and he said now you're gonna
audition so her life went like look like
that there was an acceleration to it so
I wanted to actually ask the actor to
dramatize the accelerant well first the
slowness and that was slow and then gets
a little faster and then it actually
moves quickly in a kind of geometric way
towards acceleration when she actually
auditions from home today she arrives
after driving for two weeks in a pattern
and she gets the job and it was
transformational moment in her life and
that acceleration is a part of the
dramatization of the test which is
recorded in terms of music let me give
you a couple examples Paula Rosalyn is
the Argentinian choreographer i
mentioned who's doing the work in every
way stars she actually uses Renata shirt
Alice's signature work which is named
area which is to about Aria and she asks
a piano player to be on stage and he
actually plays selected dots of the Bob
music so it's never continuous he plays
it exactly as it would be rhythmically
but he drops out certain aspects of that
there's a composer named Lucas Foster's
done something
as well so there's a way which he's
using it to point out the kind of
partiality of the of the narrative that
we only get certain points but not
everything so that's another example
there are actually music-based oral
history performance projects and I'll
just give you a couple of examples 1 is
the survivor before saw by arnold
schoenberg in which he takes what might
be apocryphal e a first or second person
narrative of someone who survived the
holocaust and he actually recreate that
in orchestral form and so for example
the Nazis are coming and saying like
everyone line up and so it uses the
brass instruments in the orchestra to
suggest lining up and then the vocal
parts are what we call strikes Gemma and
I think in some ways this book was
considered the sort of first real work
of stress in which is speak singing and
so the speak singing is rivet eyes as it
is a form of music so there's that and
then there's a wonderful work by Steve
rice named different trains which you
may be aware of in which he interviewed
people while he was a child living in
the States who would have been as old as
children who might have been murdered in
the Holocaust he saw that connection and
he was also child that shuttle between
divorced parents and so he felt like he
could have been on a train just the way
those kids were on a train going to the
camps and so the idea of different
trains is the work and he actually did
interviews with his governess who
accompanied him back and forth he also
interviewed african-american porters on
the trains about the experience of being
on trains and he also took interviews
from a holocaust oral history project
but he did was he look for what he calls
psycho acoustic fragments in which
something meaningful emerges in the
rhythm what amber of the vote
waste in the interview so for example
the porter said when we got to New York
okay so when we got to New York has a
rhythm to it and when he actually set
the music on the kronos quartet he
actually took the rhythm of that so that
was quite interesting that actually the
words come forward in a recorded tape
but you also hear the kronos quartet
playing live the same rhythm there are
ways in which those what he calls psycho
acoustic fragments are ways of tapping
into the body qualities of the words to
bring them into music so that's another
example of pure music situation yeah
discuss some of the ideas behind
presentations for those who were not
adapt
ah very good you meet in the transcripts
of an introduced okay for me the best
case scenario is if in an interview
someone uses movement and I gave this
example earlier so I'll just give it
again that I was talked to a
choreographer he said when I do my
choreography this is let me not do these
certain things in them but is that so I
waited and then I asked him okay you did
this mr. can you tell me more about that
we ultimately open-ended question he
said oh that's the crown chakra and I
use the chakra system to do all my
choreography let me give you a whole
methodological at reduce on the seven
chakras so it was clearly important but
it was embedded and so my best-case
scenario is going back to the narrator
giving them a few at most the minimal
cube do you give them that open to say
that they can say let them say it in
their own words that's my best-case
scenario when I'm describing that
movement in text right I'm trying to
give some kind of you know strong
descriptive elements you know he touched
his hand with his you know vertically
with the fingers of his right hand kind
of something like that but ideally we
shifted from sound recording to video
recordings and all of our interviews in
order to cope with you just these issues
but I will answer the question in
another way that maybe you didn't intend
i'm actually a wrote about muscle memory
and rewrote that published text as a
performance script so that actually
included all of the actors exits props
movements kind of thing and what I did
is I deeply footnoted all of those so
there's actually more footprints on the
page then text because I really wanted
to make the point about kind of the
ironies of what text does to performance
to the lobby imprint and try to see how
show how colonize is it so that was kind
around six there sorry of course so if
one of these was to go to an actual
performance yes would you provide the
audience with some of the background
yeah okay I like the performance to
stand with its eminence of work of art
I'm giving this lecture on the fourth
performance of college run she did every
Thursday night in November so many
people have seen the work already and if
they want to come back and listen to
that after the fact that's great there
will be some people who will hear it
before that so I'm really so excited to
hear your thoughts and ideas thank you
so much you're late I'm really
interested in the word authenticity yeah
and how you define it and i'll just give
you represent ask you on the spot
interesting unusually assigned Jeffrey
Burton sports cars of the spirit towards
the struggle against and thus Emma
authenticity to my class this year I did
not because some of the readings very
abstract but as a supreme word for
scholar but also weren't bringing
survivor of the Holocaust writer and the
co-creator of ammo at west washington
park tied with gail which is the first
organized Orleans Street homeless Center
in the country apartment like women
being a certain kind of way believes
against the idealization of what is and
also what could be progress because of
experience of the locals and so i'm
super-interested
word authenticity it has real meaning
and that maybe perhaps has more meaning
in the body Bobby that it could text
which was but on the other hand I'm very
appreciative of his his ability to push
himself and all of us doing documented
work to question whether there is
anything like authenticity of your most
or after the London and I'm thinking of
the work of machine horny teen also as a
way of working with torture it is it's
something you can't the way to performs
it is something you can't quite get the
young so I'm wondering what your yeah
it's a it's a keyword with many vexed
problems associated with and you know in
post modernism people would say there is
no authentic stuff because we're all
living ourselves frequently and we are
all simultaneously many many beatings
and I would certainly agree with that
and I would say that that's some of the
problems some of the critiques of
heidegger's work is that he was embedded
in a kind of pre-modern nostalgia for
the kind of agricultural VOC of the
German and you know he's deeply
criticized for that because it actually
also as part of his errand and even
those ideologies so those have been some
of the problems that he was looking for
that that artisinal the kind of craft
person in the world that seemed to be
overcome completely by the
was driving in many ways what he was
trying to do I guess what I would say is
that i'm interested in the way in which
the temporality ask that can be
separated out from the ideologies and
you know right now i'm actually reading
a text on high degree not season just to
ask myself this exactly yeah so it's a
pursuit that I have and I'm well aware
of the problems and more and more
information comes forward it seems
annually about the problematics of
Heidegger and his ideological stuff so
I'm asking myself can I use it can I use
it in any way that is helpful for moving
when I was intrigued by it was a
possibility that through the thought
talk about it in a different kind of way
than you would talk about it that's why
yeah and that's for me the most
interesting yeah
question like my background is in
psychogeography as a world performance
artist and you said specific theatre and
I've never really thought or history and
just acting so I appreciate what you're
saying I have a pressure which sounds to
me quite naughty you talked about
temporality and silence and I'm thinking
of a durational performance piece by
marina abramovic the artist is present
which was that moment is now a movie the
artist is present it's a very
significant title when you talk about
Levon the bound body she stopped there
who knows who haven't eaten for over 700
hours and did nothing in some people's
terms my question is in your terms does
that constitute world history /
completely gestural interaction mm-hmm
such an interesting idea because it's
not it there's no vocal dialogue but
there's actually all of all the embody
chance of communication and highlighted
as in self-defense it's documented you
know why ya do I remember that people
would come up and sit yes and be
interacted with her in fact even her
reaction see it's right there was you
know planter on it Frank you sit there
yep as long as the car explain yeah yeah
I think it's a really interesting idea
yeah I think it goes it takes like my
concepts and pushes it to this exports
pretty a logic yeah I also think that
site specific work is quite interesting
because in fact you are and because my
background is an architecture that has
been actually a focal point of my
choreography this site specific work and
for me there's always a way in which I
had a dialogue with the site in a
geography at the site and how do you
unleash what's embedded they're
culturally and also temporarily in terms
of historical materials i did a work on
the on the water's edge of san francisco
at the maritime museum in which the the
celebration of the
the tall ships era of maritime culture
in San Francisco was being with being
documented and housed there and we
learned sea chanteys and we either the
same wheeler to learn the movement
associated with sea chanteys and we
actually walked into the water and
submerge ourselves and so on and it was
up there was a year's work of going to
the museum and learning about what was
embedded in the site and also what's
embedded in the site is the historical
impression of Asian so you brought
through those ships to the port and what
their what was done to them and sort of
use for example some of the symbolic sat
morning with the color white certain
aspects of actually Fung Shui which is a
form of psychoanalysis in Chinese
culture so there's all kinds of ways in
just trying to unearth what was there in
the site and be a dialogue with it Ron I
kind of intrigued by the story of Jose
the end about trying to make something
that's two dimensional into yeah pretty
much yeah it says that's what we try to
do an initial you're presented with a
body of evidence and narrative at seven
episodes that is always in some sense in
two-dimensional or three-dimensional
whoever our language is such the
language of history is such that is
difficult to make it to get that third
need a dimensional or that multi
conventions and that we strive for the
proper language to do that and part of
that is striving to understand the
different technologies involved in say
the dress the myth mythological image or
of the dress contains within itself a
different time
generality than the one we are used to
as a historic gift in terms of the way
we measure time the metrics we put obama
and so that is that tension yeah between
then the question is for the apparatus
that you work done is how does our
understand of the text of the tensions
lead us to make judgments about action
in the real world mean and that's where
you you're calling upon how to remove
your core to make that transition is in
terms of first of all shows across
America risk because a really important
different issue and i miss assure it
works that that the way in which
metaphor becomes evidence is a very very
tricky tricky problem and you know i'm
trying to grow using that last store
that's an entryway into when I just
heard that red I think that if I'm read
your custody I would understand what
you're saying it must different way than
hear it so I like that image you yahoo
dimension through tuition in you you
also dimension yeah well I don't know if
this comes from but what's interesting
about metaphor for me is that it is a
vibration between the thing itself and
its reference and what the reason I use
is that then that vibration introduces
the concept of movement that the
metaphor is not lifeless that it
actually
has this shimmering effect because you
must actually hold both of those at the
same time in your mind in order for that
operation to work and in order to hold
them both you actually have to hold your
attention to both poles and then go back
and forth very quickly between them to
kind of wrap them I guess in a way and
it's interesting that you know when I
actually did this gesture with the dress
there was a way which she was trying to
wrap herself around that's I don't know
if that's actually helpful for you but
to me that it was a it was a figure that
was meant to move us towards how
movement is always embedded in our
rhetorical tropes and that movement the
reason why we even have that movement
sensibilities because we have bodies so
I'm trying to pull down the rhetorical
world into the body from which emerges
but IM use the historical trope is it
better and i don't mind that at all then
that's actually more more ways for us to
move to mobilize actually so but thank
you for I've been enjoying this
discussion on theory but I'm curious
in our program about one of the more
sort of practical concerns in doing oral
history and the arts which is smart
about funding oh and how you are able to
sort of execute these contracts such a
good question well in in the eggs i went
to the NEA during the period of time in
which hiv/aids was very apparent leigh
an issue i was invited to dance USA
which is the service organization for
our field and to speak and I would
always say whenever I spoke at that time
I'm not a historian but this is what I
do to the black I kind of asked her so
then I'm going to get the graduates me
um but I felt that there was a sense of
regret in the community for not having
really paid attention and they felt that
they wanted to honor those of us who
were trying to pay attention in the
docking entryways or other ways as a
result at least became more than a
nameless face of here at least a face
with the name in that national world of
the fun community so that when I
requested funding at the very beginning
I received five thousand dollars from
the NEA to do one a couple of these
projects the next year at the NDA
withdrew its mining the more inclined of
course and then someone told me that
David Geffen was developing a foundation
okay I'll call him up son call him up
and I think only he liked his secretary
assistant answers and he was like other
phone saying David what do you think we
got I could hear like thank you what
does he want lots $5,000 okay give it
Joe so I just had the balls to do that
that was mu
the entire NBA with one gram so it was
that kind of thing that once you're in
the granting procedure and you actually
are decent about doing your reporting
which is really important because we're
gets around because it's a very small
community if you do you're decent
reporting and you have decent projects
you actually can get funded i had i
think i received a national down the
program for the arts grants in various
categories wherever they were in the
service isn't that i think it was
services to the field for a long time in
any case i also receive funds from the
California Arts Council and in
particular it was because I did a
outside evaluation of the program of
legacies program and its materials about
let's say that was 90 choose five years
in and I brought in an anthropologist
who did oral history who was involved in
dance and she did it outside evaluation
we published it and we sent it along
with our applications I felt like I was
doing as much due diligence as I could
to prove that I was serious about being
evaluated taking advice one of the
advice points than he used in action
your application was that it was not
sufficiently diverse so we spent four
years actually doing interviews with
Cambodian dancers and proper where our
dancers of Native American dancers and
Mexican American dancer which were
amazing amazing entropies and I was so
grateful for that but I do think that
I'm thinking um they strictly about how
it is that you will be seen from the
outside and using whatever tools you
have to justify and
solidified we're busier doing and then
use those recommendations to then
launched a new grant proposal so that
actually worked for several 15 years
anything then it became quite difficult
and then the challenge was is how to
update aunty and the way we got the
Antony was being very challenged by my
archive is why aren't we doing more
famous and so what we did is we devised
a strategic plan that we would do what
was quote-unquote violent elder who was
well-known the first ballerina in Sam
cisco valet to do the nutcracker in the
30s something in fact greatly it turns
out that she was the mentor for the
first Hispanic prima ballerina and
services cavalli pretty much in the
nation who was younger not at grace but
had an amazing story but she was her
stupid so there was a relationship there
and there was this amazing not famous
flamenco dancer who was a dentist who
performed flamenco and the tabla of the
North Beach area of San Francisco and he
had an amazing story too and he was
actually a friend of the first prima
ballerina because they went to the san
francisco valley school together in the
future beans so what I was looking for
always was a translation between a
person that was well known someone with
whom they had a relationship and then
someone who was not well known who had a
relationship to vote because he was also
Filipino so it was it was establishing
even more Hispanic or or latin-based
characters in the narrated pool so that
was an example we went on to do more
like that actually I think that that
triangulation worked well as a next
stage strategy in order to generate
continued funding and it was good about
that as it was three interviews and we
got three years of pumpkin and then we
got three more years of funding for the
next
so that was a good six years that was
quite good so we really work very
thoughtful about how to be responsive to
our board of directors and the archives
and how to also be the word averse
within our own principles and value
systems of risk factor being the most
important aspect so that was one
solution i would say in terms of making
performances did I ever get funding for
those performances no I did not I made
them on my own but what I will say is
once I made them it became the engine
that ruled my solo career because what
happened is I could go to a Carlisle
Carlisle Dickinson College in Carlisle
Pennsylvania give a lecture her own
history anthropology sociology give it a
lecture demonstration to theatre
teaching a dance class and then bring
all those audiences together for
performance and I did that in dickinson
I did that in Idaho I did that New
Mexico I did that in Pennsylvania so it
was actually the engine for my touring
career because I could generate earned
income because I could justify leaving
by myself being able to serve all these
different from aspects of the same
university community and you know that
was the case I made for a good eight to
ten years so it wasn't it was earned
income not
don't help answer your question that's
great thank you and thinking more about
this relationship between temporalities
in a body mint in the oral street
interview and interested in the idea
that our bodies are sort of stuck in
time in a way right way their bodies in
the moment realistic interview we're
talking and the quality pass have caused
incredibly positive future moving all
around position in our minds of your
time and I'm wondering you because of
your training I think you have a special
ability to observe the way our bodies
acting on the stream but I'm curious if
you have anything to say about how our
bodies and our body language reflects
those smooth let's do trying as we're
talking and in the world of the street
interview maybe for narrators I guess
absolutely my doctoral dissertation
looked at one of the interesting but one
of the interesting things to merge from
the research was that people are are
more often narrating recursively than we
think they are and by recursive I mean
that they return to certain notes of
importance and so for example one of my
introduced was with a narrow a from the
12th our company actually during 911
this is hard eight is why did two
interviews before and then two
interviews the day after the day i had
to get to Brooklyn to do which was
amazing but he was very engaged with
this idea of self-reflection and he had
certain nodes in his history that were
very important ones and I considered
them that i would call stable elements
of immobilized life trajectory so in the
love of movement now
system one of the main paradigms is
stable mobile that is to say if you're
actually moving your arm it's not just
moving around you're actually stabilize
this side of your body in order to do
that because I didn't I would do that so
there's a way in which we are always to
somebody walking is an exercise in
stable mobiles and so that paradigm
actually is very helpful overall
sensibility about what movement is and
what I noticed for him is that when he
would recurse back to these knows he
would actually do these amazing this is
just one gesture in which he would do
this stable stable mobile gesture and so
that that was something that it turns
body language was the cue for me what's
going on here the same i'm asking what's
going on there this is something he did
frequently and so i had to check okay
where is that occurring in the interview
home I notice it's where he would be
purse back to a state and note his own
life trajectory so there was ways in
which that body and I which was
referring to the temporal structure of
his narrative that's one example I just
want to hear more well I did to another
example another twyla tharp dancer
actually um said to me in the interview
well she didn't say it to me she said
I'm now speaking to my future audiences
very rare right for a son narration to
have that kind of perspicacity to think
about how this interview will be in
perpetuity available to future audiences
and this was a harvard-trained story
your turn
to answer and she had this amazing sense
of her own temporality and in fact as a
result as it was being videotaped she
actually performed the interview
speaking performance she said now I'm
going to sit on the floor and now you're
going to sit on the floor and I were
going to sit back to back while you
interview me now we're going to sit
front to front and now we're going to
lean to the side pretty soon we were
doing contact improvisation during
Alaskan of the interview so this was
absolutely essential future audiences
how the body and the sense of the
narrative is actually intertwined and it
was for the future that's quite
incredible there are some of their hands
I just had a question I've been having
this internal debate about me making i
hope this question comes across as clear
but since you're interviewing
choreographers that for your oral
history how exactly is that meaning
making made clear and is there a
conversation between you and your
interviewee as suit what movement should
be representative of what they're saying
things of that nature is that clear i'm
interviewing all kinds of people in the
dance community i think it is a dance
economy so i could be interviewing an
administrator or a teacher or dancer
choreographer or even a musician so
there are many many roles and actually
as you may know dancers in the room many
of us occupy all of them at the same
time more across our life trajectory so
I would just say that their many roles
that's just one thing but I think you're
asking how in terms of my me making my
interpretation of the interview how I'm
selecting what movements or is that like
a two-person job where your interviewee
and you guys had a conversation about it
or interviewee dictates okay i want this
movement to say just a bit I suit
yourself no one has ever been that
explicit with me except that one person
actually decide to choreograph the whole
that was the novice thought sort of
extremist version of that so I would say
they almost often happen subconsciously
and my job is to actually make them
explicit and so I'll ask the question
what was that and I would say in general
if you were here for that that almost
always when I asked he has been very
fruitful but there has been a whole
narrative emerging out of that gestural
moment so I would just say that for
damage option subconscious but I beacon
explicit does that mean yes so I think
keeping your eye open to the
possibilities because you could ask an
egg salad it to mean anything that's fun
it's also fun but almost always it sends
us someone could you talk a little bit
about your own body as you are doing
these interviews and your awareness of
it and how maybe how that has changed as
you've become more and more experienced
an interview the interview respond
just looking at your position oh yeah
I'm take the position
I'm willing to go most places where the
narrator's want to go and so I'll just
get an example where I was interviewing
that God with HIV who was Filipino and
hope I and had grown up on the work
camps of the Central Valley California
and his father came with his two young
sons left to mom at home and the two
kids stayed at home and what they would
do he told me that they would put on but
if dad went to work even put on I guess
it was 60s 50s sort of Elvis music and
they would actually dance with the
doorknobs as their partners and so he
would get up he got up and demonstrated
that and I said can you show me and I'll
do it right and there was a way in which
my being willing to go there with a way
of deepening that experience in
validating it for that person and then
you know we actually danced together for
a little while to see what that was like
and then we sat down let me say the
narrative just kept spilling out of that
experience so I'm willing to go there if
it's necessary in the same way I think I
described being part of the performance
of an inhale foods ritual you know for a
week the baby mesh in this
improvisational structure in order to
gain an understanding inside that
performance to do the appropriate
interviews I'm go I'll go there and live
together in terms of just the practical
elements of doing an interview sitting
in a chair I just always aware Piper
where maybe of where they're comfortable
are not comfortable and how I can have
them be more comfortable and sometimes I
do use some of those things that we've
learned
the 70s about nonverbal communication
that you can sometimes mirror somebody
and then for comfortable sometimes you
can actually do something that's not a
mirror that actually helps them move so
this would be sagittal movement front
and back movement this person is laying
back the whole time they're very relaxed
that actually they're not very engaged
so if I actually do something of a
sagittal in the fact sometimes that is
automatically brought into their bodies
and they come forward to me and
engagement and I use those salaries so
that's another practical side yeah it's
great it makes me wonder also about what
you're talking about with silence and
how there is no silence and and maybe as
you're mirroring or engaging creating a
blankness for that opening in some sense
and and how that works with silence yes
the flow thing that we talked about
earlier I might put a tiny what's called
shape flow Bob I'm livin analysis shape
flow is just when you are kind of
flowing inside your own bodies container
I might do that as a little bit of a
cute or someone can confuse
somebody wet suggested we use rolling
chairs sipi completed yeah yeah yeah
yeah that was what you really did in one
of the essays that i read in preparation
for this you discussed this idea of
performance as a form of research
inquiry yes and so you're a writer
you're a dancer so you might comparing
stage performance and scholarly writing
as ways of interpreting world it's rude
let me start with an example that might
be a listicle estrogen for you when i
first wrote about muscle memory for
publication i talked about this elderly
woman e and she was very small for her
age and she was taken to school by her
brother and the teacher says no she
can't be old enough she can only be four
maybe five when she was and she said I'm
sick from Millie six and so they brought
the teacher back to the helm and the
parents who were Polish immigrants could
not cope with the status difference so
they allowed the teacher to to
intimidate them so that this child who
was old enough to go to school didn't go
to school for a year so that was a very
sad thing she actually the child saw her
parents objected buying power in the
status of the teacher and so I wrote
about it but I didn't think about the
body of how the body itself might have
shown that objection and so my professor
actually asked me to explore that as a
core element in movement terms what
would it mean to be objective Gucci
shrink which you stand behind your
mother would you look at your mother
which you shrink and look at your mother
what's the body experience of doing that
and that enabled me to actually get into
a whole discussion of power relation
power relations between the child and
the parent and relations between the
parent and the teacher how the teacher
might have become more like a parent to
the making the parents in two children
and maybe that the daughter actually
mirrored the objection of the parent
becoming a child all of these
complexities were actually coming out as
a result of by actually moving through
that process of being that objective
child for experiencing that situation in
a performance way so if that makes sense
that was a form of inquiry that dropped
me into this whole array of potential
power dynamics that I hadn't really
addressed in the crate test yet and then
when I rewrote the text I wanted to
reverse that sense of the performance
gain more important than the text up at
all the texts and fitness so that was
only reversing the power of the
scholarship did that make sense that's
one example you know I performed Frank I
still perform Frank know he had a um
Frank was a snap you noticed a clean is
ok who's this necklace that's it ok oh
okay oh my yeah sure yeah I've watched
tongues untied and we did this matt
davis oh yes catal that's funny right
so often african-american men and their
way in which they engaged in their drag
personas with and that was the way of
reading somebody right like be careful
of me I have energy I guess yeah exactly
and so Frank actually hang out a lot of
American bars and Hispanic bars in San
Francisco and watch the drag shifts
until he became a statically and this
was a gesture for him that was like in
your face and banquet area in your face
anyway so when I made the performance I
I did a whole section in which i did a
biographical element of him saying I
want to be a dancer and I just saw
things so I can do it right I can do it
yeah okay and then um he actually I was
throwing out of his house because he was
clear and his father came to his house
with a gun and threatened to kill
himself and Frank just basically said go
ahead do it I basically perform it like
this anxiety like he's being really rash
he's actually really anxious so I used
the snap in a different way and then
there's another point which he goes to
Luigi New York right the famous
TJ's studio and he was like watching
this and he came the snap kind of thing
so he was sort of in some way maturing
in himself and at the end of the session
where I talk about that the incoherent
coherence at the very end he literally
says to me in the interview says it's
over meaning the interview I don't want
it to be over at the end I just go
because that's how quick his love was so
that the metaphor of this of this simple
gesture had what we would call
Polyphemus it's Polly Cena's it's
multiple meaning and I think that in
using that gesture which is familiar in
different ways i was able to address
many aspects of Frank's character and
the narrative elements of his work so so
thankful
Oh